I am thrilled to report to you that the Joe
Biden administration has frozen U.S. weapons
sales to Saudi Arabia.
The Biden administration is freezing to big
arms deals with Saudi Arabia, as well as the
United Arab Emirates.
And these were approved very late in the Trump
administration and they are now on pause.
This is related to the sale of some F-35 jets,
as well as attack drones to the UAE and a
very big supply of various munitions, elements
of munitions to Saudi Arabia.
These are stopped and they are going to be
reviewed.
This would be a huge policy shift from the
Trump era and really a big policy shift in
general for the United States State Department.
And we have been talking about the has it
been I think it's been a decade that I've
been talking about the perverse relationship
with Saudi.
Arabia on this program, the senior U.S. official
who commented on this said that these are
routine administrative actions typical to
any transition.
You just were putting a pause to review pending
arms deals.
And they sort of are seemingly trying to downplay
the geopolitical significance, but I don't
think it should be downplayed.
Let's wait and see what they decide if then
they say in a month.
Oh, yeah, we're going to just go through with
it.
Well, then maybe really this is no big deal.
But so far, this appears to be a significant
a significant decision that's being made.
I like what I see now.
If we think about engagement with the progressive
base of the Democratic Party, as well as more
left leaning independents, this is a good
step by the Biden administration.
Of course, it remains to be seen what ultimately
happens with these paused deals.
But so far, there is a lot to be optimistic
about.
And very importantly, this reminds us both
sides aren't the same.
Trump spent his administration bragging about
arms deals with Saudi Arabia.
When asked about stopping the deals over the
murder of Jamal Khashoggi, he said, well,
there's a lot of jobs out there.
Remember this?
Jamal Khashoggi, the journalist, the Saudi
journalist, was he murdered by the Saudis?
And did the prince give the order to kill
him?
Well, nobody knows yet, but we'll probably
be able to find out.
It's being investigated.
It's being looked at very, very strongly.
And we would be very upset and angry if that
were the case as of this moment.
They deny it and then deny it vehemently.
Could it be them?
Yes.
Jared, your son in law's got on the phone
and asked the prince, did he what?
Did he deny it?
Did they deny it?
They denied every way you can imagine in the
not too distant future.
I think we'll know an answer.
What are your options?
Let's say they did.
Would you consider imposing sanctions as a
bipartisan group of senators have proposed?
What depends on what the sanctions.
I'll give you an example.
They are ordering military equipment.
Everybody in the world wanted that order.
Russia wanted it.
China wanted it.
We wanted it.
We got it.
So would you cut that off?
Well, I tell you what I don't want to do Boeing,
Lockheed, Raytheon, all these.
I don't want to hurt jobs.
Here's another one where Donald Trump was
asked about the same thing.
Be in favor of stopping a country from spending
one hundred and ten billion dollars, which
is an all time record, and letting Russia
have that money and letting China have that
money, because all they're going to do is
say, that's OK, we don't have to buy it from
Boeing.
We don't have to buy it from Lockheed, we
don't have to buy it from Raytheon.
And all these great companies will buy it
from Russia, will buy it from China.
So what good does that do us?
There are other things we can do now.
Donald Trump is not wrong.
I mean, Trump is right that there are U.S.
there are jobs in the United States connected
to selling weapons to Saudi Arabia.
That's true.
What makes the freeze all the more notable?
And if they stick to it and cancel the deals,
all the more brave is that there are jobs
connected to this and there will be people
who say anything that creates jobs must be
done, no matter how unethical or immoral or
counter to our stated values as a country.
If Joe Biden sticks with not going through
with these sales, there will be some jobs
on the line.
That's true.
And it will make what is a morally correct
decision all the more significant.
I didn't expect to see this yesterday and
I am quite pleased we will follow it to see
where it ends up.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at Dipak The David
Pakman
Show at David Pakman dot com.
The David Pakman Show
at
David Pakman dot com